it's shaping up to be a big week for eu
economic affairs after the ecb announced
an unprecedented rate hike yesterday eu
economic and finance ministers are
gathering in prague for an informal
meeting
at the top of the agenda the looming
recession caused by high energy prices
and record high inflation in europe
finance ministers will also be
discussing financial support for
war-torn ukraine german finance minister
christian lidna announced he wants to
push for the oil price cap agreed on by
g7 countries
well i'm joined now by dw's band riga
who's at the conference in prague band
good to see you a lot of chatter about
how to bring down prices for consumers
what options are ministers considering
yeah after the ecb the european central
bank acted yesterday the ball is now in
the field of the finance ministers they
have to come up with some measures
to fight inflations and one of the
foremost millers would be a sound fiscal
policy so less stepped but on the other
side they want to ease the pressure on
prices for consumers there are many
eight packages
under development and that would
actually heighten the debt of
the finance ministers and the public uh
households so it's very difficult to
find a balance here and ministers are
not
agreeing on what measures to take the
southern countries want more that the
northern countries was want less debt
and but all agree that
inflation has to come down somehow and
the ministers don't have an actual
direct impact on the prices here
okay we're talking about agreement here
g7 countries have been talking about a
price cap on russian oil for months
russia and opec have been a warning
against it now germany is pushing for it
why is that
well germany as the presidency of the g7
announced today that they want to push
for
a price cap actually the g7 has already
agreed on a price cap um they want to
shave off revenues for russian state
oil companies
so that there will be no gains from this
war anymore for mr putin
on the other hand there's the danger of
course uh that doing this
the supply of oil for the world market
would go down and that that could
heighten prices actually on the other
side again so the g7 is now looking for
other
customers of russia to join them to have
this price cap and to push the revenues
of russia down it's more a political
measure it's not a direct
impact on the prices worldwide actually
okay well obviously a lot of elements to
debate there are any concrete proposals
coming out of the meeting so far
well no concrete proposals but the
ministers have to agree uh how to deal
with public finances and fiscal policies
there must be a solution they cannot
push it or
kick the can down the road um so they
had to come up with a
rule how to get rid of public debt
in the eurozone in order to avoid
another crisis
which we have seen in 2015 with greece
for example this recession this crisis
can easily develop into a state debt
crisis and also euro crisis
and prague thank you for that
europeans are being urged to save energy
this winter to avoid shortages for some
companies that's impossible leaving
shutting down the only option
duralex is one of the world's most
prominent glass producers but it soon
won't be producing at all
the french company says it's halting
operations for four months this winter
due to the cost of gas and electricity
ceo jose luis jacuna sees no other way
to save the business
between january 2021 and january 2023
the price of electricity will have been
multiplied by 22 and gas by 18.
in these conditions our production lines
are worthless
if we maintain production our energy
costs could represent up to 40 percent
of our turnover which is untenable
duralex needs lots of energy its
gas-fired furnaces melt glass turning it
into tableware at 1400 degrees celsius
the current volatility of energy prices
is a nightmare for the company's boss
the first thing i do when i wake up in
the morning is look at the daily change
in electricity and gas
prices it's truly a roller coaster and
the outlook for the future is complete
unknown
jose luisiacuna says if the crisis goes
on it would mean the debt of the
industry as he knows it
well to just discuss this further i'm
joined now by karen pittle of germany's
ifo center for energy climate and
resources karen thanks for joining us
are these types of shutdowns that we
just heard about an example of what's
happening all across europe not just in
france
yes definitely i mean industry structure
in different countries is different
energy price hikes are also different
electricity in france is
among the worst in europe but still this
is can be observed all of across europe
for example in germany the industry
association
estimates that about 10
of firms already decreased their
production or
shut it down
and it really it boils down to the
question is whatever the firm produces
replaceable by something else so can
they increase their prices because the
product is absolutely needed or is there
imports or other types of things that
can be can replace their product and
that basically determines which leeway
they have to pass on the prices to
customers
okay well 10 already shutting down
that's quite a dramatic number i mean
what would widespread shutdowns like
these mean for the economy as a whole
that really depends crucially on which
type of firms are actually
shutting down if it's at the end of the
value chain so it's basically just the
firm that is impacted it's still not
good for the economy but if it's
somewhere in the beginning of the value
chain so their product is used in other
firms in other firms and so on it can
lead to cascading effects and that would
make things much worse
okay well do we have any chance of
avoiding uh this sort of worst case
scenario i mean we were just talking
about the cap on russian gas prices for
example
any way to get around this this problem
not completely i mean what we also just
heard is about the debt crisis a
potential debt crisis um for the
governments so i mean the prices are
there the costs are there for energy and
it really is the question how can i go
about that i save those firms which are
especially important for the economy and
how can i prevent the others to shut
down permanently so kind of
trying loan programs trying also to
support the workforce or the firms in
keeping the workforce
excuse me such that they don't have to
lay people off so it's about minimizing
the impact it's not about avoiding it
completely
that was karen piddle from the efo
center for energy climate and resources
thanks for that analysis
you